ready and set to go Travis Boyd Brett Howen for
the drop and away we go in pre-season game four
hi everybody dan Dua Sheriff Shane NY here
for the nights and the coyotes Vegas team
gold coyotes with their kach uniforms white with
black green starting on defense for the golden
night Shan it's Nick Hagen ktie Cor Z corac
with ha back defensively Carlson sets up he
for the lead to Center little tap Doria the corac
Z those are signs of chemistry here early on mtio
with career highs last year and pretty much
everything Thompson gets a piece of that shot
from defenseman Maverick Laro his connections to
the team or you know Josh he's going to have an
eye on what the coyotes are doing MCN reaches in
times that perfectly reach with the stick pass
intended to Liam O'Brien down the wi now MCN
LS it up the ice got it to ktoa who angles it
on goal first man there defensively LL Kia shot
interception at Center working in brassat with
barbashev now eel bumped from behind barbashev
gets a shot toward the goal it waffles into the
corner oh long path to a championship seven in
the pre-season 82 in the regular season another
22 in the playoffs derit keeps it alive P
watching derit again with a head fake and
a cross for a shot that is turned away on the
doorstep Justin Kirkland Thompson watching the
play right in the slot and a shot that goes in
the goal for defenseman Maverick Laro right has
the penalty time expired the 6'7 defenseman
from Ontario and a first round draft choice
gets the first goal of the game into this whole
play is right there a little no look past the
inside two guys pressuring and then mat to
able to poke that over to laroo I believe
it's Leonard who makes that pass great play by
him and then Laro comes in the 19-year-old set
67 left at 29th overall amadio steals it back for
Vegas dorthia on the outside amadio in the corner
got it across for corac fought off by Andra in
the lane and a good pass of Mato as BAC goes up
high tring to get it over that left shoulder
he got a couple of the good looks here for
Vegas theall behind his
go looking for kson it didn't connect Rand
to high for Theodore Jay fakes left this
over right towards the goal through the blue
ice Mel looking for bran but just behind him
and out of the Zone I like to see that from
Shay theer that means you know you're getting
back to that game speed when makes a play
like that his ability to bounce down from
the Blue Line rad takes a hit tries to keep
the play alive barbish for eel Jack to Hay a
wrist shot he [Applause] [Music] scores tie
game Nicholas hay puts it home second point
in his second pre-season game he get a free
Puck and eel watch the protection comes out
you can see heg creeps to that middle ice a
better shot Lane and what a shot by heg is
eel little backhand saws out to the point bunch
of sticks in front but he just Rifts that pass
just over 79 miles an hour rer that snap from
the flex able to wrist it past the shoulder of
EG becomes the eighth different golden knights
goal scorer here in the preseason eight goals
eight different scores looking for more mcams
onetime blocked oh Travis durman hobbled a bit
after getting in the way dearia tried to tie
up couple of coyotes in the neutal zone Arizona
manages to dump it in from former Toronto Maple
Le Travis durman who heads off the second go
Brown fresh on the ice keeps the buk in the zone
for his mates forwards going to it steter and up
the wall will Carlson starts the break out for
aadia two onone with Doria aano for dorv sliding
split save for Conor and grook in a game plus
36 minutes here comes theor shooting glove save
Ingram well he could get it it back into play the
referee Lewis whistle just comes down the middle
Lane and does a real good shot Ingram reaches
out left GL hand to make the stop but really
like Shay Theodore you can tell the difference
from game one to this game that's ni had a power
play goal against the Kings two days ago and this
group by the back of the n in front a quick shot
stopped trying to tip it toward verer if he was
trying to shoot either way L with a Qui chance set
up by Carlson here's a Faceoff win for VAs rad
for coren aist shot locked in the slot rebound
score Brendon rad puts Vegas in the lead
2 one power play goal great play by Brett
Howen starts in the face off look at the
face off win the support to come in and
help by bran little catch with corak just
a shot through and here's Howen little kick
out passes that puck gets blocked in the
high slot everybody's looking around how
it just kicks it all to a wide open Brandon
bran no chance for Ingram on this one bran
second and then Brendon bran on the power play
from alen and corac with 15 seconds to go in
the second five on four for Vegas beginning the
third going right to left in goal HCK Pok out
High sod challenge for Michael Boyd collects it
in the slot and then forced wide from Carlson a
drive off the post and secure somehow by Thompson
well he got all of that one a bit of a loose puck
just slips past eel there's the onetime in front
and see the screen Dome kind of slashes in front
of Thompson takes his eyes away for a second
and Odom gets all of that one pass the glove
sign on Thompson but right off the post and
back underneath Logan is as he falls back on
that puck without a goal for the coyotes and
if the golden knights can do so it would be
their first pre season win Byron frases wants
to extend the lead frases toward the open cage
off the side of the net it looked like he was
impeded in the last little bit of that now a
try and into the goal for Carlon empty n 31
golden knights seconds away from the victory
he mentioned phas some great work by him don't
comes backs just enough contact to push that
wide but then Carlson follows up some great work
in the corner he comes down and he's going to just
let this back hand go and through the golden
I there he sees the open net able to just the
remaining crowd to its feet another terrific
pre-season crowd here at the Fortress they rise
to celebrate a victory the victory Flamingo
onto the ice golden knights three coyotes one